We can't think of a more
interesting and exciting time
to launch this course.
Yes, there are challenges
that you and your peers
will face because my baby
boom generation didn't
do a great job of keeping
our policies and practices up
to date with the changing
economy and the changing
workforce.
But at the same time, we're in
an extremely interesting era
of innovation.
Around the world we're
seeing new organizations
getting formed
using crowd sourcing
and other modern techniques,
organizations we couldn't even
have imagined several years ago.
There are new worker advocacy
organizations coming along
that will help empower you
to find your way in the labor
market.
There are new apps that allow
you to navigate this labor
market and to figure out
where the good jobs are
and distinguish between
good and bad employers.
And then there are courses
like this exploding
all around our universities
here in the United States
and in other countries.
We rise and fall on the
strength of our middle class--
These online courses
allow you to gain access
to some of the world's
leading experts
in your particular field.
The role of the corporation in
the US has changed quite a bit.
So it's time to really
bring all of this together
and see if we can't help really
shape the future of work.
We're going to introduce
you to lots of companies
that are breaking new ground.
In every industry we
can find great companies
that are doing well financially,
serving their customers well,
focused on a mission that is
really important for society
and providing good jobs.
One of the things we want
to do is to highlight those
and to learn more about
your own experiences
with companies and
organizations like this.
And so as we go
along, we're going
to learn from your
experiences, and you're
going to meet a
whole set of peers
who have good jobs and maybe
not such good jobs, some mentors
who are ready to work with
you to provide advice,
and all of that will be a
learning process together.
And let me say a word about
another piece of this course
that I'm especially
excited about.
In every week,
we're going to have
something called the
personal development corner.
This is designed to
provide you with a path
forward so that you can be
empowered to take control
of your own career.
So there'll be
readings and videos
and exercises and
assignments that allow
you to understand what are
some of your capabilities, what
are some of your interests,
what jobs might fit well
with your background,
and where you would like
to go with your own
career; and how will
you develop your own personal
career plan to make sure
that you are ready
to take advantage
of the opportunities
that are out there.
So let's start exploring this
evolving and interesting world
of work.
Let's do it with our eyes open.
Let's understand and
learn from our history
about what worked in
the past, what's broken,
what needs to be fixed, and why.
And then let's
see if together we
can't shape the future of
work for your generation.
So let's get started.